Good afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to our session on intratumor drug responses.
My name is Oliver Jonas, and I'm the chair of this session.
The focus of our session today
addresses one of the central challenges in precision oncology, and that's really a
twofold question. The first part is: how do we understand
what the drug is actually doing inside of a patient's
tumor when the treatment is happening?
And then a question related to that is: how do we connect that information to what
we routinely measure in the clinic
through the imaging and pathology and the clinical outcomes,
such as symptom progression and survival?
In many clinical settings,
what we still see
is basically what's outlined here.
Let's see if I can show my mouse.
No.
I guess we don't have a cursor yet. But
is that there's essentially
some baseline biopsy in some tumors, molecular profiling that's done,
and then the patient
embarks on a course of treatment, and then we typically monitor that treatment with
imaging
over the course of weeks to months.
And oftentimes, the first measurement
could be an MRI or a CT, is often about six to eight weeks out.
And then over the course of several months, we assess clinical responses and
outcomes.
But what we really miss is what's actually happening inside the tumor,
and that's the focus of this session.
Oops, let's see. The slides are not advancing.
Is there any way to
activate that?
Thank you so much. Okay.
So what we'd like to learn more about is that critical window
from when we start treatment to when we do that first imaging and when we
understand what happens at the larger scale, what happens at the size of tumor
shrinkage
or tumor progression,
and certainly what happens in terms of patient outcome and survival.
During those initial days and weeks, we miss
all the molecular biology and all the critical cell biology in terms of target
engagement, in terms of pathway signaling shifts, all the metabolic
reprogramming that happens pretty rapidly,
and the early events of immune modulation.
And so as a result of that, the clinical decisions are lagging far behind
the tumor biology.
So the opportunity here is to use new technologies, such
as the implantable microdevices that we'll introduce today, and
spatial profiling
of drug responses in the tumors that look at protein and signaling,
the networks that look at metabolic mapping,
and that can do all that
in a spatially intact way that let us not only understand the bulk measurements,
but also the single-cell
responses and cell-to-cell interactions that make up
the overall response of the tumor.
So with that, I'd like to introduce our first speaker,
Professor Sean Davidson from Northwestern University.
He has done incredible work in tumor biology with a particular
focus on tumor metabolism.
His work has pioneered the use of spatial mass spectrometry techniques to map the
distribution of metabolites within tumors
and provided new insight into how metabolic networks are
rewired in response to therapy. He has applied these approaches
across multiple cancer types,
including prostate, pancreatic, and breast cancers, and we're very excited to hear
about his work. So please join me in welcoming Dr. Davidson.
Great. Thank you for the kind introduction.
It's very exciting to be here today to share this work, which
has been ongoing since I was a graduate student.
And
before I jump into the main story, looking at cell type-specific metabolism,
I'll go into a little bit of background about
how we got here.
So,
it starts with the invention of the implantable microdevice.
So I was a PhD student at the Koch Institute at MIT, and I was
working one floor below Oli when he invented this
device in Bob Langer's lab.
And this was really the point of the Koch Institute, I think.
Phil Sharp wanted convergence and the
convergence between scientists and engineers, and it was just such an exciting
place to be.
At first, we would sit in the lunchrooms, and people would talk about, as a
biologist, I'm hearing about quantum dots and all kinds of things.
But it really worked, and I think this is living proof.
So I'm happy to share this.
So Oli invented this implantable microdevice, which is about the size of a grain of
rice, and you can
put
many different drugs into that device, and then you can
implant it into a tumor, and then you resect the tumor,
and then you section through the device and you can get
spatial readouts, and you can get drug response
within the tumor itself. So you implant it into the mouse,
and now there are many clinical trials, I think
human clinical trials using this device.
And
you implant it, and then after a certain amount of time, and this is very different
for every assay, if we are looking at protein or if we are looking at metabolites
we might change the duration, but it can go from hours to days to
weeksAnd then we can extract it and do
different assays on this.
So
at the time, I was
in Matt Vander Heiden's lab studying cancer cell metabolism,
and we were working with and collaborating with Dafna Bar-Sagi at
NYU. And Dafna made the original observation about a process called
macropinocytosis, and that was that when you inject oncogenic RAS into rat
embryonic fibroblasts, they transform, and they have this thing where they start
doing membrane ruffling that's actin-mediated.
Now, this is bulk endocytosis.
It wasn't appreciated as its own cell biology process until
the '90s, but this was really important.
Now,
it's interesting to think about this because,
in many ways, macropinocytosis doesn't make a lot of sense.
Cells work really hard. They spend a lot of energy trying to maintain chemical
gradients across their membranes and trying to get nutrients
inside. And so by doing this random, non-specific
process of macropinocytosis, all of those things kind of go away.
So it was unknown at the time, even though we knew that the cancer cells were
doing this, it was unknown why they were doing that.
So it was only years later when Cosimo Commisso
joined Dafna's lab and was doing experiments, and that's where
I jumped into this project. So Cosimo did a really interesting experiment
where he
took RAS transform cells, which are critically dependent on glutamine in
vitro.
Many of you have grown lots of cancer cells, and you know you have to add
glutamine, and you know if you don't have glutamine, it doesn't go so well.
And he made an observation that he could grow these cancer
cells successfully in low-glutamine conditions
if he supplemented extracellular protein.
And so the logic followed that maybe these cells are taking up protein into
the cell, breaking it down into the constituent amino acids, and then that's what's
feeding the cancer cells. And indeed, that's what happened.
And so this is what was going on. We grew
13C yeast-labeled protein, and we fed it to cancer cells, and
we realized that about 30%, and it depends on the system, but somewhere
around 30 or 50% of free amino acids in K-RAS transform
cells come from extracellular protein.
So this was really exciting, and this was all happening in a dish.
And we wanted to know how much of this is happening in vivo, what are the relevant
substrates, and Ali walked through the lab with a prototype of this
microdevice, and I was looking for people to
have a metabolic application.
So we did this first experiment with the microdevice where we implant it
into two xenograft cell lines, and we
deliver rhodamine-labeled dextran or DQ-BSA.
DQ-BSA is a caged fluorophore of bovine serum albumin,
and you can see in the cells that have K-RAS transformation that the
cells take in albumin or they take in the heavy labeled protein,
and they also take in the DQ-BSA. And it's
important, this caged fluorophore, this means that it goes to the lysosome,
and that's how it's uncaged. So not only is it going in, but it's also going
into the lysosome, and that makes sense with the free amino acid
observation we saw. And in contrast, BxPC-3, not a
K-RAS transform cancer cell line, does not do that.
So we wanted to go a little bit further with that, and that's where MALDI imaging
mass spectrometry, which is the main focus of my lab, comes into play.
So
MALDI is a
way to do spatial metabolomics. I'm not going to go into it too much today,
even though that's normally what I would exclusively talk about.
But you can take a frozen tissue section and coat it with a matrix,
and then you ionize it with this laser,
and you can get a small molecule spatial
resolution of
around 15 to 20 micron. And there's a lot in the
works and in development to improve that.
And this was a very useful technique to study this process because then we
could actually use the microdevice, put it into a K-RAS transform tumor,
and we could deliver an inhibitor of macropinocytosis
called EIPA. And so the logic was that if you deliver
EIPA and inhibit macropinocytosis, you're cutting off the nutrient supply
line, and therefore you may expect depleted amino acid
levels in the tumor. And so we delivered that, and so we used MALDI to
visualize not only the distribution of EIPA, and that's important, and I think in
this educational session, I'm going to emphasize the different ways that we can use
MALDI.
So you can use EIPA, and then we saw in that
cell line, so
this is the K-RAS transform line,
that EIPA has an effect and there's a decrease
in amino acids, and it's better seen below here.
So this was the beginning of everything and putting everything together.
And then we started to ask what else could we do with the microdevice?
What else can we deliver? And so I spent a little extra time in
Boston before I went to develop this mass spec
technology in my next step. And
again, in the spirit of an educational section, we've delivered a lot of
diverse molecules. I think we would probably have a pipeline number on the
percentage that we've actually done.
I think some of these, we had a nice base editor, so we can deliver base
editors.
We can do genome editing.
I particularly like this antisense oligo approach because you can
kind of buy them off the shelf and put them into the microdevice and then deliver
them. So it's great to assess essential genes and
test hypotheses around that. And we can deliver
CRI.We've delivered inhibitors and enzymes,
and what's really cool about this is you can actually deliver
the drug, and then you can actually use MALDI to see how the
drug is metabolized. So we have a CDK4/6 inhibitor.
We can see the parent molecule, and then we can also see the metabolite
products that you might expect from that process.
So it's a very powerful thing, and you could imagine implanting this into a liver
or into a tumor. And I like to think about it
as a way that it's kind of a way to reverse efficacy.
So you don't always know if the drug is going to get there when you dose it
systemically, but you know at least you know if it does get there,
that it will or will not work. And I think this approach uses that.
And then it's a different engineering problem to actually get the
therapeutic to the tumor.
We're doing some other things in that space.
But one thing we thought was it might be interesting to use this to try to
study immune cells in the native microenvironment.
So we know that tumor metabolism shapes the immune response, and
lactate suppresses T cells, adenosine shuts down
antigen production presentation, and
nutrient competition can starve immune cells.
There's probably a million other things that we still have yet to discover,
inhibitory molecules.
And so it's really exciting, but it's a very difficult thing, and so measuring
this in the tissue has been impossible until
recently.
And
so most approaches were using
FACS sorting, and so by the time four hours of FACS happens, metabolism
has changed quite dramatically. So we thought we might
take a different approach here.
So our approach combines four things.
First, the implantable microdevice.
Next, we did
CyTOF to tell us what cells are where.
Then we do MALDI imaging mass
spectrometry, which is my main contribution to this work, and
then we also collaborated with Ernest Fraenkel and his talented graduate student,
Veronica Pister, to
increase our ability to do complicated computational
analyses that integrate this
incredible multimodal data.
So we started off with this study, which was a continuation of a work that was
done by Zuzana Tolarova.
And Zuzana
screened many molecules to try to see which molecules would
stimulate specific immune responses.
Because remember, we wanted to get immune cells around the reservoir
so that we could actually study a population of immune cells.
It's hard to study things on serial sections, and so we wanted to try to increase
the biomass and try to get
more of a response. So these were the most interesting
drugs and combinations, and they also had-- There was
mechanism to understand and learn from this.
So we included some of the most
interesting ones. We included--
Sorry. We
have controls. So we have
the conventional chemotherapeutics, so doxorubicin, and
the vehicle control, where there's just nothing in there.
And then we also used a PARP inhibitor, a STING agonist,
and some of these other molecules.
The molecules on top here, these were the ones that were some of the strongest
phenotypes, so we will follow that and go more into
characterization of those.
So we took this, and from the CyTOF data, we built a map
of all of the cells in the tissue that we were able to stain positively.
I think we had
15 markers or so at the end of it. And then we just asked what
cells tend to be neighbors, and that gave us nine
recurring neighborhoods, and four were immune rich,
and one was a cell death zone.
Venetoclax specifically
recruited 30% immune cells, and the PV
drug treatment resulted in the most cell death, and
that was such a powerful one, we had to separate it in the reservoirs
so it doesn't cause major effects.
So we now have these interesting neighborhoods that are a
response to the drug.
And so
we next asked in the metabolomics, we profiled over
27 tumor sections,
which is a quarter of a million data points,
and just from the imaging mass spec alone, and this is
hundreds of metabolites, and it's untargeted, so there's actually--
You get all of the data in this set.
So this is one of my favorite early
figures because it's a feel-good data.
So you have tumor here, and you see some of the usual
suspects. So these are the nucleotides.
This is what you might expect when tumor cells are dividing.
You need to make more nucleotides to self-propagate.
And then we look at the
stroma, and we see TCA intermediates
and amino acids. And nicely and
provocatively, glutamine and glutamate kind of sit at this intersection, which
could be some crosstalk, whether one is using
glutamine and the others are consuming glutamate.
And we'll follow that up in further studies.
We also observed something separate, which was a lipid signature
for
some of the cells here, which we'll come back to in the context of
the different immune cell populations.
And finally, we identified these gray ones that
we associate with cell death. And I think in, at least
in vitro,
these form a pretty strong signature
of cell death.So this is what the data
looks like. So you can see where the micro device was, and you can even see
this red notch here. It's very small, but that's where the
reservoir was, and then the drug came out into that region.
So we can get these spectral clusters.
And so you can see citrate and iso-citrate mostly in the stroma and the
fatty acid in the tumor, and
then further characterization and kind of extensive class
labeling of all of the different components that we found
there.
So this is the key finding from all of that data.
And so the volcano plot shows what's different about the cell death zones.
So enriched on the right is the purine catabolites, so uric acid,
mandelic acid, adenine, and guanine.
And these are breakdown products of
nucleotides.
Sorry.
Sorry. These are breakdown of nucleotides.
And then depleted on the left, you have glutathione and
more nucleotides.
The GSSG-to-GSH ratio
around this reservoir also indicates oxidative
stress and is elevated in cell death.
And uric acid being one of these, this is also a known
danger signal that
has been shown to activate inflammasomes.
And we would have more work to do to show that in our system, but
it's an interesting first observation.
So in contrast, this Venn diagram shows that
there's metabolites enriched in these
mosaic clusters. The tumor regions are full of macrophages.
The macrophages aren't dying.
It's full of macrophages, but the tumor cells are not dying. That's important.
And then in enriched, we have DHA and EPA and arachidonic acid,
and so this is kind of a lipid program.
We can see that
depleted are all the purine catabolites that were seen on the previous
slide, and so effectively this is the metabolic
inverse. So we have two populations of
macrophages, and
one population is pro-tumor, and these have high CSFR and high
CD206.
And we have another population of immune cells
that we weren't sure exactly what was going on.
But
it's
basically to say that there are two metabolic states, both with macrophages,
and we get opposite outcomes. So this is important to know
and to follow. And the other
sentence summary of that is that
purines are kind of the thing that say fight, and lipids are the thing that
say stand down.
So if metabolism was encoding the immune state
precisely, can we actually predict what cells are there from metabolites
alone?
And this is important because we could do maybe one assay instead of
optimizing a lot of antibodies for CyTOF for every different tumor.
And so if this was true and we could actually get something out of
metabolomics that was indicative of immune cell state,
we would be able to have a nice
readout for this study.
And we did a simple logistic regression here, and
these ROC curves
are really exciting. So on the left here, we have
something that
might make sense. So this is the H&E pathologist, and we have a nice
ROC curve here that shows
the correlation between
the histological region and the metabolites.
But more importantly, we found that we're able to predict the
cell population based just on the metabolite.
And so we were able to correlate that to the ground truth where we had
immune cell staining. And so
this is
really exciting to us because we think that it could be a marker
of proper response.
And here's the spatial proof. So on the left, the ground
truth, immune neighborhoods defined by CyTOF protein markers.
And on the right, our model predicted
using only metabolite data from a serial section.
So you can see those predictions are quite strong
in really
validating what we saw in the original ROC
there.
So
where do we go from here? I think there's a lot left to
do. So when you measure
metabolites,
and you measure metabolite abundance,
you don't necessarily know about the direction or the flux
of these metabolites. And
in order to actually get flux and different nutrient contribution, you need to use
stabilized stroke tracing. So using that could give us more insight into
metabolic pathways that are active.
We need more on the temporal dynamics side, so
from one snapshot in time
to multiple. And then the human translation, so what
out of this data can we actually use in potentially a
clinical assay at some point? So
it's very exciting. And with that, I'd just like to
thank my funding,
AACR, and Stand Up to Cancer, and CRUK,
NIH, and the members of my lab, especially
Veronica Pister, who did
a tremendous job driving some of the computational efforts
behind this project. So with that, I'd like to take any
questions.
Could you use the microphone? Thank you.
Thank you for the presentation. I saw you mentioned the micro
devices can deliver different compounds, include mRNA,
even bacterias. So I'm curious, because these
different compound, the molecular weight or structure are very different.
So what's
the factor that determine the release profile from this micro
device?
I'll take the first draft, and I'll maybe let Oli take the second draft of that
one.
So the molecules themselves, sometimes it
depends. So we can load them in the micro device kind of as is, or we
formulate them with different molecular weight PEG, and that's
just to control where it's going. And so
for some of the smaller molecules we might use like...
Or if we want slower diffusion, we would use a larger PEG,
so that it just takes longer to release.
So it's either we formulate them in different molecular weight PEG or
we just have the molecule in there.
And then that is one of the hardest parts, and that's why this project has taken
so long
is optimizing the conditions and
all these things.
Oh, yeah. Sorry.
I have a second question very fast.
So, these micro devices can release different type of
drug at the same time?
How to make them in the same device and
control their release?
How it happens? They separate into different reservoir
or there are some other way?
Yeah. So through a lot of hard work, Oli has optimized the spacing
between each of the reservoirs. And
it's
imperfect sometimes if you put it into a necrotic core and there's a lot of liquid
sometimes. But in a perfect tissue, in a perfect setting, they're spaced
far enough apart that there's no drift.
And we've done a lot of experiments with fluorescent compounds to show that.
Basically, red, green, and if there's no channel merge and just making sure that
that's the case. And we're formulating some other things for
just using fluorescent PEG as a delivery agent, so that we
can see that. And it's really nice because if you have four fluorophores, the way
the device is laid out, every level
has a unique
orientation, so you always know that it was that.
So yeah. And it's a little finesse sometimes.
Thank you.
Great talk.
How much do you think of those immune-specific
metabolic signatures are enforced by the tumor
cells? Or they're just inflammatory programs that are being
repurposed? Or are they response
to certain cytokines that may be driven by certain mutational
events, et cetera?
Yeah, that's a great question. And I think that's why, yeah, we definitely need the
temporal analysis to catch them early in the middle and kind of
at the end to see
those things.
Thank you.
Does anyone have anything they want to deliver?
Okay.
Again, thank you again for your talk.
I found it very interesting, especially how you started talking about using
MALDI to look at the different metabolites and characterizing what kind of immune
cells you have in there. I guess one question I did have is how does this compare
against, well, more traditional ways of looking at it, like flow cytometry for
immune profiling and whatnot?
What was the first one? I heard immune profiling.
Conventional-
Oh, using flow cytometry for immune profiling.
Yeah. So the reason that we went to this was just because metabolism changes so
fast that by the time you do FACS, and people have systematically done this,
there's just major changes in redox metabolite levels.
So the thing you're trying to study when you do FACS and dissociation from that,
it's four hours later. And metabolism, when we're doing these assays in cell
culture, we're taking the cells and putting them on dry ice just to
stop everything as fast as we can. So, it's just a very fast,
metabolism especially. So, that was really the appeal
of using this.
Thank you.
Okay.
That's
good. Great.
Okay, thank you, Sean. That was a wonderful talk.
So
that segues nicely into our next presentation, which is
how do we measure drug responses in the tumor and associated biomarkers directly in
the tumor microenvironment?
And we talked earlier about the sort of need to collect more data
during this clinical treatment window after treatment is initiated, and then before
we get the first systemic measurements from imaging
or from surgical specimens in some cases.
And where this really comes to play is in treatment selection
for patients. So
the
traditional
selection
of treatments is based on what's the standard of care for a given treatment,
and then
that is given to the patient, and we have to wait weeks to months until we know if
that treatment actually works. And if it doesn't work, the patient goes on to the
second-line treatment, and in some cases, the third line.
There are many different cancer drugs to choose from and indications.
They're often given in combination.
So it's a very complex problem.And of course, the goal of precision
medicine is to not have a patient go through those
cycles of treatments that may not be effective,
but instead to have the treatment identified that's going to be the most effective,
and to give that right off the bat.
There's a related problem in drug development.
So, as everyone here knows,
the path from developing a compound pre-clinically to having it
approved is very long and costly, and I know those numbers
are in flux, but I think they're only going in one direction, and that's up.
And in addition to that,
the
majority of agents that make it to the late phases actually fail due to
a lack of efficacy. And so understanding much earlier
if a given drug is effective, and in what patient population or
subpopulation it would be effective in, would be very valuable and would help us
develop drugs faster and more effectively.
So with that in mind,
we wanted to develop an assay that would actually
work in the patient,
because we know that tumors
do not just depend on the patient's genome, but
also on the epigenome, the transcriptome, the proteome, metabolome, as Sean showed.
And all those factors contribute to the phenotype, to the actual drug response.
So several years ago, the FDA developed a concept
called the Phase-zero Microdosing Concept as part of the Critical Path Initiative.
And it provided for a streamlined
regulatory process to test novel agents in patients,
sort of faster
and much more easily than for a traditional phase I systemic
study.
The original intent, or at least the original use cases, were
more for
PK studies. So a small amount of drug,
and the threshold is usually 1% of the systemic dose,
would be administered IV, and then we could learn how the drug distributes in the
body.
But the insight that we had, or the idea that we had,
was that we could deliver that microdose directly into the tumor, and as
long as it's less than 1%,
and as long as we can keep it local inside the tumor, then we can actually have
therapeutic level
drug
within the tumor, and we can measure how the tumor responds to those drugs.
And that's how we came up with the implantable microdevice assay to actually make
those measurements inside the patient, and to make those measurements not
only for one drug, but for many drugs in parallel.
So the way this assay works
is that a small device that's about the size of a grain of
rice and has a large number of reservoirs on it.
It's typically about 20, although we have a few variations of that.
And the device is delivered directly into the tumor with a biopsy needle, and then
it resides in the tumor for a set period of time.
Usually, it's about three to five days, but that can be varied based
on the drugs and on the measurements we're trying to make.
We always place multiple devices in the same tumor, so typically four
to six,
and that allows us to measure the response of the tumor to the same drug in
different locations. So we understand the role of the local
microenvironment
in modulating drug responses.
And what's really important is that we've now, and I'll show some data on that,
delivered this into many different solid tumor types.
So we think it's amenable in general
to any solid tumor that can be reached with a biopsy,
and we've done studies showing that there's no systemic
drug exposure that's detectable, even with the most sensitive techniques.
So we're able to deliver a drug. We can do
it in a very controlled and precise way, and do it locally in a way that
allows us to multiplex different measurements at the same time.
So the way the workflow looks in the clinic is that the devices are
placed in the tumor, and then when they come out, they're extracted with
surrounding tissue,
so that can either be harvested at the time of surgery or with the
new version of the device that we have that can be retrieved with a second biopsy.
And then this device tumor specimen
is processed, either fresh frozen or FFPE, and then we section through
that device tumor specimen,
and we get a cross-section of the whole tumor
with the device in the middle, and you have your different treatment zones that
are in spatially confined regions, and you have
untreated control tissue directly next to it that you can compare
to your drug effect.
What's also
been the subject of a lot of work and development is being able to do this
with many different modalities. So we've used a lot of small
molecules and antibodies,
and more recently, some ADCs,
and even some cytokines. There's a somewhat different
delivery and formulation mechanism for each, so
we've had to optimize that. It's mostly based
on polymers, and the polymers act as a sponge that can release each
of the compounds in a controlled and precise manner.
So we have
the
chance there to tune the exact concentration of drug
that gets released into the tumor.
And what's really important also is on the tissue that we take out and on which we
do the measurements, we're able to see the drug
distribution and the local drug concentration, and there's different ways to do
that. And Sean showed a little bit
on how mass spec is really useful for that.
So what you can see here, for example, is a tumor cross-section
where you have the device in the middle and you see your local delivery zone.
You see a spatial gradient there. I'll talk more about that in a
minute.But in addition to
detecting the molecule directly, you can also detect some of
the sort of formulation components or stabilizers that are part of the clinical
formulation for almost all drugs.
Or you can have fluorescent tags, for example,
with which you can see the drug directly into the tissue, and these are examples
here of different drugs. And there's also a few other techniques that we haven't
used,
but certainly you could use, for example, tissue capture microdissection into
LC-MS or other techniques to quantitate the amount of drug and the gradient that
you get.
So, what's really important in order to understand how a drug works is to get the
concentration right. So early on, we did a lot of
studies trying to understand the
local drug concentration that makes it to the tumor when you dose systemically.
For some chemical agents, that's known from the
literature, but for other agents, you have to do that measurement yourself.
And so we figured out ways to tune the concentration of the drug locally, again,
through that polymer formulation so that you can match locally
what you would get in the tumor from systemic dosing.
And then clinically here, an example from our GBM patients
showing that you get a very
consistent drug release profile
based on these formulation techniques.
So one interesting aspect of this is
when we release drugs locally in the tumor from the reservoir, we get a
concentration gradient that's distance dependent.
So close to the reservoir you have higher concentrations, and then as you get
further away, you have lower concentrations.
And what that really allows you to do is sort of a localized PK/PD measurements
for each of the different agents that are on the microdevice.
And you can overlay the concentration gradient of the drug with
measurements
of drug effect or of efficacy, and there's a couple examples of that shown here.
This one is for CLEAVE caspase-3, showing tumor apoptosis as
a function of concentration, and on the right is an example of the
androgen receptor for two different drugs from a
prostate cancer patient.
So, just two different examples of different PD
readouts that you can make spatially
by taking advantage of that drug release gradient.
And then, as Sean mentioned, we have a lot of efforts underway to
integrate different types of measurements.
So this is an example here of spatial transcriptomic
profiling of cells, and you can use that information to understand
the effect of the drug on
the different cell types that are present in the tumor treatment zone.
So not just the bulk measurement, but even at the single-cell level and certainly
at the cell type level to understand
the
specific effects, for example, on the tumor cells versus the T cells,
and so on.
So one of the early studies that we did,
and this is still a preclinical study,
a few years ago, was to see, okay, can we use these measurements to actually
predict systemic sensitivity of the tumor and ultimately of
the patient
to different drugs?
And in this study, what we did is we had a number of different agents that were
delivered into different tumor models.
And for each of the agents, we noticed that there was a very unique tumor
drug response signature,
and that consisted of an effect on the tumor cells, but it also
consisted of effects on the macrophages and on the T cells.
And we found and then showed in systemic studies
that the local phenotype that you get from
the drug exposure can be used to
predict a combination agent that's going to lead to a superior efficacy.
So in the example of palbociclib, we see the emergence of
protumorigenic macrophages in the treatment zone, and those can be combined then
very effectively with an anti-CD4 antibody,
and you see that that gives you the superior response. Same with the venetoclax.
Whereas the panobinostat, for example, you see the antigen-presenting neutrophils,
and those are effectively treated with
an anti-CSFR antibody. So we showed that we can make
this measurement for different drugs in the tumor, and for each of them,
based on the actual responses, we can combine that treatment
with an immunotherapy and get a superior response.
So then the next step, of course, was, okay, we want to do this in the patient.
And so we,
since then, have initiated 13
clinical trials in different tumor types, have placed over 350 devices into
patients
with an excellent safety profile. There hasn't been a single serious adverse event.
And we've tested a lot of different therapies,
both on the small molecule side and the large molecule side, and a lot of
combinations as well.
And another aspect that's exciting that I'll say a little bit more about at the end
is the ability to use this platform to test novel
compounds that are not yet approved,
and, most recently, even pre-IND agents with a
very minimal tox package,
and to be able to generate clinical data much earlier and faster than you normally
would with a traditional Phase 1 approach.
So I'd like to show a few applications of what we think are the three
primary use cases for this intra-tumor platform.
The first one
is maybe the most obvious one, that's the personalized selection of treatment.
So the idea would be you put this device in a patient,
you load it with a lot of different approved agents that are relevant for that
specific cancer type, then you measure how the patient's tumor responds
to all the different treatments, and you pick the one that is
the most effective.The second
application is on the drug development side, so to be able to get
human data much earlier, much faster, and to understand
target engagement mechanism,
dose-dependent efficacy,
and biomarkers. And then the last application I'll say a little bit about at the
end,
and that's to use the fact that you have
a large number of pharmacological perturbations that you're putting on a single
tumor,
and to
essentially ask, what can I learn from the many perturbations that I can't
learn from one?
And we've now,
through these studies, built a sample library of over 6,000 unique
tumor drug phenotypes, meaning tumor sections that are treated with a unique drug
in a unique patient.
And we're working on some modeling and machine learning-assisted
ways to understand that data and to integrate the biomarkers
into specific,
potentially better treatment outcomes and treatment hypotheses.
So I'd like to walk you through an example of how that process is played
out in real-time.
And so this is sort of the story of our clinical study in
glioblastoma. So as everyone here knows, it's an
extremely deadly disease, one of the most deadly tumors,
and there are
relatively short times to progression and
terrible clinical outcomes. So the purpose of this study is to
test a large number of different treatments, some of which are standard and some of
which are not, so that we understand how to better treat these patients.
And this is what the clinical workflow looks like.
So this is an example here of a patient
that presents in clinic.
The
devices are then inserted. You can see here two microdevices are inserted
here, one and two,
and then three days later, the patients go to surgery,
and the device tumor specimen, which you see here, and you actually see the two
device tops sort of poking out of the
tumor sample, then go to the lab, and we do the biomarker analysis.
Meanwhile, the patient goes on adjuvant treatment for the primary
tumors. That's in most cases temozolomide,
and in the recurrent tumor setting, it's
either lomustine or there are a series of other options as well.
And then the goal is, of course, to correlate the observed clinical
response with
the
predicted response from the biomarkers on the microdevice.
So this is what the sort of surgical and interventional procedures look like.
So this is what the microdevice looks like here
for the study. The surgeon inserts it through a minimally
invasive burr hole.
You can see how the devices are placed here.
There's one already in the tumor,
and then there's a second one that's being placed right there.
The devices then stay in the tumor for three days,
and then at the time of retrieval here,
the surgeon is extracting the entire tumor, but he usually first
takes out a piece of tissue
from the middle of the tumor containing the devices, and
we get that specimen in the lab, and then the patient's standard surgery continues.
And that's the specimen then that's analyzed in the lab.
So some of the measurements that we can make
are sort of
confirming
some of the mechanistic
and concentration-dependent measurements that are
either known or unknown about some of these treatments.
So the example here on the left is a DNA-damaging
agent
for which we profiled the concentration,
and then you can see directly overlaid with that concentration, you can see
different measurements of tumor response to the drug.
So it's a DNA-damaging agent, so you have markers here of
DNA damage,
and then
a
reduction in proliferation here as measured by PCNA,
and then you have your measurement of apoptosis, cleaved caspase 3.
So it's a nice way to confirm that the drug is doing what it's
supposed to do in terms of DNA damage, but then also understanding
sort of that pathway from
stopping proliferation to causing DNA damage to actually killing the cell.
For the targeted agents that we had in this study,
we were able to do some spatial transcriptomics and sort of
as a first step confirm, is the drug actually doing what it's supposed to?
Is it hitting its target?
And there are examples here for some of these different target agents like
osimertinib, an EGFR inhibitor. So you see the pathways that are most
down-regulated are related to EGFR.
For lapatinib, it's EGFR and HER2.
For everolimus, you have your mTOR signaling.
For abemaciclib, you have your cell cycle and cell cycle
checkpoints
that are down. And then you also see some interesting things, okay, what happens
that
may be less expected? Abemaciclib, for example, you see some strong interferon
upregulation. So it's an opportunity to not just
confirm that the drug does what it's supposed to, but also see what else is
happening in response to the treatment.
So sort of an unbiased biomarker discovery.
In the first pilot cohort of patients, so these were the first six, we had three
patients that received systemic temozolomide.
And what we found here is that we had one patient that had a strong
response. You can see that here in the radiographic imaging.
And we had two patients that essentially had no response or had disease
progression.
When we did the microdevice measurements
before the systemic therapy was initiated,
we saw that patients five and six, which are the two on the bottom here, had low
response on the microdeviceBiomarkers of DNA damage, and that
patient three had a very strong response, and it turns out that
that's what we saw clinically as well.
The patient who had the strong response on the microdevice also had a strong
response clinically, and the two that had a weak response also had
a weak response clinically. And interestingly, that was independent of the MGMT
methylation status, which
in the first and second case would have predicted the opposite effect.
So you would have expected the partial methylation to most likely not respond, and
the methylated patient to be more likely to respond.
But the clinical outcome was different, and the microdevice measurement
predicted that correctly.
Since then, we've moved to a larger cohort, a second cohort with
seven primary patients and five recurrent patients.
And of the seven
primary patients, four of them received temozolomide systemically.
And you see the first patient on the top here had
a very weak response. Well, essentially no response to temozolomide.
You had tumor recurrence already at three months.
Same with the patient on the bottom in blue.
You had one who
sort of had a weak response in terms of tumor progression, and then one who had a
very strong response. And again, that was the unmethylated patient.
So as is shown here, and I think as is pretty widely known in the field, the MGMT
methylation status is not a great predictor.
It's the best we have clinically, but it's certainly far
from perfect.
But the interesting thing from our perspective was that the
prediction that we made, or the measurement I should say, that we made
before treatment was initiated based on the microdevice showed
that
patient number 12 in red should have a strong response, and that patient
ended up having the strongest response out to 18 months.
And that the patient with the sort of weak to intermediate response
was the one who had
a sort of medium response on the microdevice, and the two weak responses ended up
being the patients that had the very low responses clinically.
So
it's
obviously a small cohort size, but these are all the patients in the primary cohort
that went onto systemic temozolomide.
And in each of those cases, even when the information from the methylation
status was conflicting,
the local measurement inside the tumor predicted the patient's sensitivity
correctly.
From the recurrent cohort, out of those five patients, two of them
received lomustine
as a second-line treatment.
One of the patients had a
pretty good clinical response, was out to about five months
or six months, so
well above average for this patient population.
And one patient who had a very rapid recurrence.
And that ended up being
reflected or predicted again by the microdevice measurement that was made
before these patients went on to treatment.
So we had a strong response
that ended up predicting the strong clinical response
correctly and a weak response that predicted
the weak clinical response correctly.
So only two patients, but again, the prediction based on the actual
measurement in the tumor
correlated
with the clinical response and the clinical outcome for these two patients.
So our
goal
was not just to say, "Okay, can we use this to
predict who's going to respond or not?" But we also wanted to understand the
sort of response and resistance mechanisms
in these patients that are treated with temozolomide.
So we know that the ones that had local response on the microdevice also had
systemic response.
And so we
did some spatial transcriptomic profiling of the tumor sections.
An example of that is shown here. You have your device in the middle.
You have your different treatment zones.
The temozolomide
is over here. And then using the spatial transcriptomics, we're able to
spatially map
a lot of pathways.
We use a 1,000 gene panel that ends up mapping
hallmark pathways with sufficient coverage.
And so you can map the response of the tumor to each of these different
treatments, in this case, the temozolomide, across all 63 of those
pathways.
We were then interested in
asking the question of which pathways are up or down-regulated
when the drug is effective versus when it's not effective.
So what's different when the drug's working versus when it's not
working? And so this is an example of a lot of these hallmark pathways.
Each chart is a different pathway, and you have your cleaved caspase-3 on the
x-axis and your pathway score on the y-axis, and each dot is a
unique treatment zone from
across the cohort of patients.
And for temozolomide, there's a lot of the sort of expected pathways, DNA
damage-related cell stress and so on.
But one of the interesting findings was that
in the high-efficacy cleaved caspase-3 regions,
you have a very strong interferon response program.
So it appears that
from these local measurements, it appears that
when the drug is effective, there's a role
of the interferon pathway
in either responding to the local drug effect or even being a
part of it, and that's going to be the subject of future studies.
There's a couple more examples I wanted to show from other
clinical settings. So this is
cutaneous T-cell lymphoma.
The
ability to do cell type-specific gene expression patterns and to
examine those for different treatments in patients, I think, is a really exciting
opportunity. This is an example of treatment with mogamulizumab,
which is a relatively new drug
that has a specificA role
for NK cells in
its mechanism and how it's effective.
And we were able to show some
very specific gene expression patterns in response to mogamulizumab.
So just a technical demonstration of how
mechanism-specific measurements that are cell type specific can be made
with a very precise drug release and those spatial
profiling techniques that we're employing.
And this is another example from the same study, taking it a
step further. So this is a treatment with pentoximab vedotin
in a patient with CTCL. You have your treatment zone where you can
use the spatial transcriptomic profiling to
identify the different cell types.
And then for each of the different cell types, you can map the different pathways.
So this is the interferon gamma response. You have your JAK-STAT response.
And then you can take it even a step further and look at specific ligand receptor
pairs that are relevant for that
specific drug or for that specific tumor type.
And you also map those spatially.
And then the last example is from
treatment with a checkpoint inhibitor in a patient with head and neck cancer.
So this is a figure I really like because it shows that you can
capture the sequence of events
of what a drug does in the tumor. So for pembrolizumab treatment, what we
observe is first the myeloid programming.
So you see changes in CD68 and MHC-II
in CSF1R, and you can identify those cell types.
You see them strongly enriched in the treatment zone.
As a next step that probably takes a little bit longer is your cytotoxic T cell
activation. So you see a higher influx of your CD8 positive
T cells and granzyme B positive cells.
And then the last step is your cleaved caspase-3,
shown on the right here, that's enriched in the zones that are
higher in your CD8
positive population. And so you can
tease apart that process of what a given drug does in a tumor,
and look at the different factors in the tumor microenvironment and how they
contribute to drug response.
So the last thing I wanted to mention is: how do we actually do
this
in terms of the regulatory path? Because I think this is a really interesting,
innovative
way in which the FDA has helped us
make this a reality. So it ends up being a relatively
straightforward process, where you submit your IND.
The IND doesn't have one drug. It's got 20 drugs on it.
And then the FDA
gives its approval, hopefully, but it usually does.
And then the protocol goes to the IRB, and then there's often a little bit of back
and forth with the IRB, and then the study can
proceed. If we then add additional drugs later to the microdevices,
we do an amendment. So
there's a master protocol that covers the drugs, and then you can make specific
amendments. And those typically take no longer than 30 days.
So it's a really rapid way to get novel agents
into the clinic and to start collecting human
data, and that's one of the aspects of the work that I'm particularly excited
about, is this path to clinical data much faster, much
earlier than we can with phase one traditional
approaches, and to start gathering data on mechanism,
efficacious doses, which combinations to test.
You can do all those combinations in parallel in the same patients,
even test the same drug in different tumor types.
And then, of course, do all this much
faster and at lower cost, and then collect actual
human PD data.
So the last thing I wanted to mention is a couple of other presentations at the
conference that are using the microdevice
platform. So the first one is by Dr.
Fanny Santa,
who's
showing some results from our clinical study
testing 20 different treatments in head and neck cancer patients.
And the second one is from Dr. Annie Nguyen from
Flare Therapeutics, who's presenting results from a microdevice
study of a novel drug candidate that's targeting
PPAR gamma in patients with bladder cancer.
So for anyone who's interested in learning more, please check out the posters on
Monday.
So with that, I'd like to thank the people in my lab
who've done a wonderful job contributing and leading a
lot of these projects. And to our clinical collaborators, especially Dr.
Peruzzi, who's leading the GBM study, and Dr.
Larocca, who's leading the CTCL study, and acknowledge our funding support.
And I think we have a few minutes left for questions.
Mark Malkin, neuro-oncologist, Cleveland Clinic.
This is brilliant.
I have a comment leading to a question.
So this helps me explain now why some of my elderly
patients with unmethylated GBM
exposed to temozolomide
actually respond.
And some of my young patients with IDH mutated
methylated GBM auger in after two maintenance cycles of
temozolomide because we're just giving it with not
really knowing what's going to happen.
Every week in brain tumor
board,
we see a lot of patients who can't have the kind of
resection that you illustrated. Their tumors are in an awful
position. They cross the corpus callosum.
They can only have a biopsy.And the problem is that after
we've done our own histopathology next-generation
sequencing, there isn't enough tissue to send out to the sponsor
of a clinical trial to verify what the molecular
signature is
to determine if they are or aren't eligible for a clinical trial.
So I wonder if you could use this technique when you see an MRI scan that
looks like a GBM and you know you're only be able
to do a biopsy, it's the right clinical thing to do, that you put the
device in
loaded with drugs as you just did,
and then three days later you take it out.
And you can actually do the biopsy and insert the
microdevice, I think through the same catheter.
Yeah.
And
instead of then by default, putting patients on
temozolomide, maybe identifying something like an EGF receptor
inhibitor that might be a better choice for them.
Yeah.
So that's a wonderful suggestion. Thank you.
I think we're
thinking along those lines and a new version of the device we developed that can be
retrieved with a biopsy,
only so that could be used potentially in patients that are not surgical
candidates.
Great talk. I know there's a lot of controversy on whether
or not the PD-1 and CTLA-4, those drugs are working
in the tumor or in lymph nodes or in the spleen, and the
timeline they work on. Do patients need one dose with the neoadjuvant
data in melanoma, or do they need years of
PD-1 like we give in kidney cancer?
I guess, can you comment on things you've learned from the device and then
maybe strategies to put these in lymph nodes or other
tissues to try and get bases of immune
response and resistance?
Yeah, for sure. So that's a really good suggestion, and I
can tell you that we are putting devices into lymph nodes.
The first
study that's doing that is for prostate cancer patients.
And the idea is that you're able to
place the device, without
need for surgery and being able to understand also
what the responses are in metastatic patients, because ultimately that's what's
going to kill the prostate cancer patient then.
So that's a very important step and we're on our way to
doing that.
So you mentioned that the device can potentially also be used to deliver
multiple drugs. And, I have to wonder, have you
tried that and compared it to a
systemic drug combination,
just to see what the difference is?
Because my point is that drug synergy
is not always as predictable as we would like.
And there's many reasons for that.
It's obviously drugs not working in the right timing,
drugs not having the optimal concentrations in the tumor, et
cetera. So I'm wondering if perhaps these
microdevices could be used to optimize drug synergy.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, that's a very good point. So, I think
the ability to
detect the concentration of drug precisely and understand how much concentration do
I actually need to elicit a certain effect or a certain degree of effect, I think
is really important. And I think in the combination question,
it's really central.
So
one way that we're hoping to answer that on the microdevice
is by having different reservoirs where we have single agent and combination
independently in different
parts of the tumor. And then also have the combination
release
in the opposite order. So we can release agent one first and then
agent two second, or we can do it in the reverse order and then compare them and
see which is better. And I know there's been a fair amount of work
pre-clinically,
to show that that can make a huge difference,
in terms of the combination efficacy,
which of the drugs you prime with, and then
which one comes second. So I think understanding that has a lot of potential to
improve combinations and identify the parameters that
are going to make them more effective.
Sorry to ask this question, but when you initially
showed the images around the device, there seemed to
be a halo effect
based on the concentrations. However, when you showed the spatial
analysis, you showed different clusters in
different areas rather than a halo effect.
Is that because you were trying to show something different,
or is this something mechanistically different?
Could the device be blocking a blood vessel or causing a
microinfarct and giving rise to the changes that you are seeing?
Yeah, so I think that's also a really important point, is we need to understand
what does the insertion
of the needle and of the device itself cause.
So we routinely stain the tissue for
markers of inflammation, for example, for neutrophils,
that are sort of the fastest responders, and then, of course, for blood vessels.
And you can see the blood vessels very nicely on the staining.
You see them in relation to where the drug is released.
And occasionally, we also notice clinically if the device is placed and we
accidentally poke into a blood vessel, there's going to be a lot of backflow of
blood. So then what you typically do is either wait until
the bleeding subsides or you place it into a new region.
So I think that's an important consideration.
It's something that we can resolve nicely with the spatial
measurements.
And you typically see injury effects from the needle only in
the first,
I want to say about three to four layers of cells.
And the drug diffuses much beyond that.
So
you're able to tell apart
what's caused by the
presence of a foreign body in the tissue versus the actual drug.
And that's really thanks to all the different sort of spatial analysis techniques
that we're employing.
Thank you.
I just have a quick question. You showed
the concentrations of the drug as it got smaller, as it diffused out.
And then with your MALDI-MAS spec,
can you show drug inside cell versus
outside of the cell with that? Is the resolution enough to say-- Because what's
outside the cell isn't necessarily what's in the cell, and that's kind of critical
in target engagement, and that would be so
important.
The MALDI spatial resolution isn't prepared to be
subcellular. There are things in the works, so there's a nice paper
with a 1.4 micron ion source, so you
might be able to get that kind of precision.
The best bet is to find the closest metabolite of that drug
or
the metabolite that you deliver. And then you could see that it was metabolized
inside the cell. Or you could use 2-deoxyglucose, right?
And then that would get trapped inside the cell.
So it really depends, but
yeah, I think. There are different ways to get at it.
Thank you.
Okay. Sounds good. Well, if there's no more questions, then I want to thank our
speakers, I want to thank the audience, and I hope everyone enjoys the rest of the
conference. Thank you.